I'm Neil Patterson welcome to the Daily
and look it isn't exactly breaking news
that for many many people it is
incredibly difficult if not impossible
in fact to get on the housing ladder now
even staying on that ladder just got
that much harder my husband and I bought
our first home at the end of September
2021 we saved really hard for a modest
deposit it was a five percent deposit
and we were paying through the nose for
rent so we wanted to get on the property
ladder at long last and actually have an
investment an asset that uh that was
ours that is 34 year old Rachel and like
many others she and her husband felt
certain that stretching themselves to
take on a mortgage was the right
decision the advice at the time
um was that even though we'd be starting
off on a relatively High interest rate
of 3.62 that would come down after our
two-year fix ended
number one because we'd added value to
the property and but also because
property prices would probably continue
increasing and that would gain us access
to better deals but that hasn't happened
instead High inflation strong pay growth
and the rising cost of borrowing means
mortgage rates of above six percent not
below four and that is going to push
Rachel's monthly repayments up by
between six and eight hundred pounds
it's a really difficult situation for us
you know we feel like we did everything
right we took the expert advice we did
everything we were supposed to do we
worked hard sacrificed anything that
could be considered a luxury
um we haven't had a foreign holiday
since our honeymoon four years ago
um you know we don't do meals out or
expensive trips
um anything like that you know we live
pretty frugally the difficulty with that
kind of lifestyle is that it's really
hard to cut back even further when
you're already kind of cut back as it is
eye watering energy bills food prices
through the roof petrol diesel still
historically expensive I know the UK
faces an extended mortgage crunch if
you're lucky enough to still have any
pennies I'd start carefully counting
them the Situation's really difficult
it's really painful uh it's it's not
what we wanted it's not what we expected
we'll just have to see what the future
holds I'm losing sleep over it
and I know that we've had lots of
discussions at home regarding finances
and how we get through
all we can do is hold on and try our
best and hope we don't lose our first
house after two years people have told
us that we should have predicted that
this would happen we should have known
that we made a mistake
um buying the house that we did
I just wonder where their crystal ball
is and and whether or not I can borrow
it
now some will suggest that perhaps a
Saving Grace is that today only 30 of
households actually have a mortgage
compared to around 40 back in 1989 but
what happens in the housing and mortgage
markets can raise its ugly head
elsewhere complete no one is Sky's
business and economics correspondent the
impacts of this
homes but let's let's start with those
who do because that's that's the
starting point so if your mortgage rate
is exceeding six percent now that might
not seem like a lot for people who got
their mortgages back in the 90s you
remember paying mortgage rates of around
but you've got to adjust it for the size
of the loans that people are taking out
now in comparison to uh their incomes
back in the 90s people weren't taking
out the kind of loans that they're
taking out now so if we're trying to
assess the squeeze how painful it is and
we adjust mortgage rates for that while
this is on a par with the 90s if not
worse it's deeply deeply painful for
homeowners now for people who don't own
their own homes who are renting well the
people who own the homes they're living
in are probably having to remortgage and
face these kind of costs so if your
landlord is remortgaging and suddenly
they're facing the kind of mortgage
rates that homeowners now are facing
they're either going to have to sell
which reduces the stock of homes
available reduces the supply increases
the demand
which means that your rents are going to
go up
or they try and pass on some of those
higher costs to you which means your
rents are going to go up so in simple
terms if you've got a mortgage and it is
about to expire you're about to pay what
several hundred pounds more a month
you're remortgaging between now and the
end of next year when the bank of
England base rate is p
then on average you face an extra 2 000
pounds a year
what then is this link between this the
base rate the interest rate that thing
set by the monetary policy committee
whatever that is at the bank of England
and mortgage rates what is the link
between the two so inflation is at the
core of all of this we all know about
the cost of living crisis we all know
that prices are rising our rampant pace
and inflation is is quite stubborn we
thought we'd be over the worst of it by
now but it's proving quite sticky Bank
of England's got it wrong and inflation
quite a few times though haven't they
the bank of England has got it wrong on
inflation consistently
um you may remember when inflation first
became an issue as we emerged from
lockdown
economists and the bank of England use
the word transitory this isn't going to
be a sticky problem we're going to get
over it pretty quickly but it's proved
more and more stubborn we all know food
prices are rising at almost close to 20
in the supermarket everywhere you go
prices are rising and one of the tools
that policy makers have to squeeze
inflation to get a grip of it is by
raising interest rates it's meant to be
painful because that way you reduce the
demand in the economy and you can get a
grip of prices
so the bank of England is Raising
interest rates to try and dampen
inflation
now when the bank raises interest rates
lenders also respond to that so when the
base rate Rises mortgage rates rise as
well but it's not just what the bank
rate is it's about expect
s of where the bank rate is going to go
so financial markets are constantly
making bets about where they think
interest rates will be
and expectations of the bank rate have
risen consistently as inflation has
proven to be more stubborn than we
thought and this is filtering through
into the price of our mortgages so was
this situation that we now found
ourselves uninvitable could was there
anything that anyone could have done to
avoid us seeing interest rates and
mortgage rates of this sort of scale I
mean you could invent a time machine go
back in it and stop Liz trust and
quasi-quarting from opening their modes
I suppose the bank of England has
consistently been grilled on this why
have you got inflation wrong why why why
did you think it was going to Peak
earlier than it did and the bank will
turn around and say well a lot of this
was out of our control a lot of
inflation in the UK is imported
inflation first we had the energy crisis
which was out of many of our hands uh
the war in Ukraine the impact that that
had on wholesale Energy prices and in
the UK we were really vulnerable to that
because we use a lot of gas to heat our
home so Rising gas prices gas prices
filtered through into the prices we pay
to heat our homes
a lot of that was beyond our control but
there's a real debate around whether the
bank failed to spot other issues like
Rising food prices why are food prices
still consistently high in the UK so
yeah a bit of controversy in that area
so what is what is now going to happen I
mean let's be fair about this there
isn't there isn't a point at which all
of the pain kicks in for everyone and
people mortgaged on different days
throughout across the course of the year
but there are hundreds of thousands of
people who are very very immediately
going to be feeling the crunch to
feeling the pinch in their pocket aren't
they yeah they're about two over two
million people that are remortgaging
between now and the end of 2024 which is
when the bank rate as I said will be
peaking for them it's going to come as a
huge shock because at the beginning of
the year we thought that we would be
past the worst of it at that point so
for them this is something that they may
not have factored in to their in into
their household budgets but if we take a
broader view so the bank starts raising
interest rates the end of 2021. in that
five-year period to the end of 2026 on
aggregate households will have paid an
extra 15 billion towards their mortgage
payments when we compare it to the final
quarter of 2021
three-fifths of that is still to come
so that puts in a little bit of context
about where we are and where we're going
three-fifth is out yet to come and
presumably quite a large chunk of that
three-fifths comes very very close to a
general election a lot of it comes very
very close to a general election so this
is going to make for quite uncomfortable
listening for the government I mean both
you know kirstama and Rishi sunak have
come out and said yeah we are not going
to be bailing you I mean I can perhaps
see the rationale from the government's
position but I mean isn't the labor
party a big fan of the Magic Money Tree
these days
really really difficult
porting mortgage holders homeowners at a
time when home ownership is falling when
many people can't afford to buy their
own homes
it's not the most palatable policy for
renters even though this does affect
them it's an indirect benefit
um that might be quite difficult to
swallow so are we not going to be seeing
significant numbers of repossessions
because of all of us
it all depends on how Banks responds and
how lenders respond
um and and how much leniency and support
they're willing to extend
to their customers but certainly in the
1990s when we saw rates hit 13 percent
it did lead to repossessions it did lead
to a lot of pain for homeowners so
there's a lot that remains to be seen
and one thing that it is worth pointing
out
is that people go to Great Lengths to
keep hold of their home you might cut
back on food you might cut back on
heating you might cut back on luxuries
but if repossessions start rising in
number that's a really really worrying
sign for the general economic health of
the country but basically this is going
to be an issue for anyone taking a
first-time mortgage anyone remortgaging
until those rates company six percent
and and be
and beef renters
people are putting more of their money
towards servicing their mortgages then
they have less money to spend on
luxuries on food on going out on eating
out and all of these things
negatively affect the economic
well-being of the country it dampens
economic growth but unfortunately that
is something that this policy in many
ways is designed to do Rising interest
rates is meant to dampen economic growth
it's meant to hurt
are we are we headed towards a recession
then I mean we're talking about some
mortgage payers you know shelling out 50
55 of of their income on their home I
mean that's not sustainable yeah it's
interesting isn't it because
we thought we'd be in recession by now
and we've managed to skirt a recession
so far but it doesn't cost but at what
cost exactly and it doesn't but it
doesn't feel like that we may have
avoided a technical recession but what
good is that when the cost of living
crisis is causing widespread pain for
households we're in low growth economy
but we're also in a really highly
inflationary economy stagflation and
it's hugely painful for households it's
why the office for Budget responsibility
the UK's government Watchdog thinks
we're in line for the biggest drop in
our living standards the biggest
two-year drop in our living standards
since the 1950s
so we may have technically avoided a
recession but it certainly doesn't feel
like we have are we then talking about a
generation perhaps two generations for
whom home ownership which it just just
will not be a prospect at least for a
decade or two yeah yeah well it works in
two ways so you have
when mortgage rates go up when
affordability becomes more difficult for
people who own their own homes some of
them will be forced to sell as we said
that increases the stock of homes
available which means there might be
some people who could afford to get on
the ladder when they previously might
not have been able to they might be able
to save up a little bit more and buy
their first home
however
there's always a butt with Euchre yeah
there's always a but because although
house prices may fall and there are
certainly some forecasters who say that
they will all of their certainly points
to a drop in house prices
suddenly you're facing quite tight
lending conditions it's harder for you
to get a mortgage if you're a first-time
buyer the the multiple that you'll get
on your salary has also been reduced
many lenders have withdrawn products
from the market
so
falling house prices might seem like a
good thing if you're trying to buy your
first home but everything else is
conspiring against you
the conventional wisdom look it has
always been that money in bricks and
mortar isn't just safe but it's actually
a sensible way of getting a return on
your investment but the old adage that
what goes up must come down is also
applicable gronya Gilmore is director of
research and insights at estate agents
cluttons so what we've seen is a housing
market that was very busy very active
right during the pandemic so average
house prices across the UK and up on
average you know 18.5 percent in the
three years between 2020 and the first
quarter of this year so we're now seeing
a market which has been very busy with a
lot of upward pressure on prices and
we're seeing the impact of higher
mortgage rates on that market and that
does indicate that house prices are
going to start
um coming back we have that ultra low
interest rate period that people got
used to but it was called ultra low for
a reason it wasn't in line with
historical Norms but what we're seeing
is that stretch Point may be that
interest rates are going to rise higher
than people expected even couple of
months ago and that's what's having an
impact in the Market at the moment our
following house price is a good thing
for buyers for buyers of people wanting
to get into the market and they'll want
to adjust but often they're not looking
at the short-term decision that they're
not looking to get in and out of the
market quickly this isn't a normal
investment this is somewhere to live as
well obviously you want to make a wise
decision but you'll be looking over the
medium term so if that looks like good
value to you over the next five seven
years then that's the that's how you'll
base your decision I see gronia you knew
that podcast presented of you
acquaintance had a mortgage coming up
soon would you be advising them to move
pretty quickly onto a variable or a
fixed rate in a market such as this
there's just so much confusion there's
so much instability around I I and other
people in this position are not exactly
sure what to be doing with themselves if
I knew someone in that position I would
say it's definitely an individual
decision because the real point of fixed
rate mortgages is you have security so
you know what it is if you're even if
you're fixing at a higher rate than
you're previously used to you know what
is happening to your household finances
for the next two three five years
the variable rate it just means that
when when interest rates do start to
fall you might benefit from those Falls
but we're not sure at at the moment and
you'd really want to read the mood music
from inflation data that's out next week
and the bank of England's um kind of
update on interest rates next week just
to see where the mood music is there
with Central Bank
um to decide whether you're happy to
take the risk because you may see some
more Rises before you start to see Falls
but I would be looking at a a kind of a
Tracker rate linked to the base rate if
you want security that that
um those rates are going to come down
just as soon as the bank of England
moves let me put my professional
pessimist hat on just for a second
gronya and and try and take us back to
you know the situation the country found
itself in in the in the late 80s you
know we had inflation running in double
digits we had incredibly High numbers of
repossessions you know people people
were generally genuinely concerned about
the future of their home ownership do
you see this as as being as bad as it
was back then
I think there's a sort of and kind of
safeguards that have been put around the
mortgage markets certainly before the
global financial crisis I mean we had
mortgage um mortgages out there at 125
of the value of the home there was so
much there was almost a guarantee house
prices are always going to rise and I
think we're not in that situation now
and we haven't been even with the very
bumper period we had in the housing
market there there hasn't been that
assessment house prices will always rise
every single year I think there's been a
kind of an awareness that this can go up
and down and an awareness that interest
rates will rise there is no doubt that
some homeowners will be under put under
more pressure because of the rising cost
of living at the same time as these
mortgage rate Rises but it's not a
one-off shock we've known that this is
coming and what's happened in the last
couple of months is it's not a case of
we're getting up to four percent it's
the fact that it's just stretching a bit
further to five and six percent and that
may cause a greater number of homeowners
to feel more pressure as we move through
the next year or two but to me it
doesn't feel like that swoop sudden
shock to the system and where the global
financial crisis where Banks couldn't
lend again a sharp shock to the system
but I'm not in any way saying that there
isn't going to be more pressure on some
homeowners across the country to what
extent does the availability or lack
thereof of housing stock in the United
Kingdom play into the situation that
we're discussing
uh the shortage of housing has been a
long-term problem for policy makers
um across the country we don't get
anywhere near what the government's
targets are for house building and I
think now that we don't have many
targets for house building and there is
a clear lack of supply and supply where
it's needed and in the price bans it's
needed in and the tenure it's needed in
so anything to encourage more homes to
get more homes into the system to bring
down that very high kind of imbalance
between demand and supply and the
housing market which is one of the
factors that puts such upward pressure
on pricing during the pandemic
and perhaps about to ask the wrong
person giving given who you work for
over at Clinton's uh but but I am
wondering in this country we we do have
an obsession with home ownership that is
not necessarily shared with some of our
closest closest Neighbors in Europe is
it perhaps time for the United Kingdom
to reappraise home ownership as as being
a goal suction a goal of adulthood
I I think that's it it's more a societal
thing isn't it rather than just plain
finances but if we're going to do that
then we look at a rental market where
the changes to legislation means that a
lot of individual buy select landlords
on who we rely to provide the vast
majority of the 5 million rent private
rented properties in the UK the the tax
changes that have been introduced the
regulation changes that have been
introduced everyone wants to create a
system which is fair to tenants and
gives them more security no one would
deprive that but there's other changes
that have happened for landlords which
means that landlords are now leaving the
sector putting even more pressure on the
supply of rented property so I think
until you can balance out those two
sides
um then that's going to be a problem
shifting uh the focus away from home
ownership and perhaps then just just a
word of reassurance perhaps even for
some of our younger listeners that this
Market does tend to go in cycles that
there are horrible horrible moments and
then there is reprieve and release
absolutely and it can go at different
times in different areas we saw a real
in central London markets we saw a real
Resurgence in those markets very soon
after the global financial crisis and
then the rest of the country followed
from about 2013 of course the global
financial crisis ran from kind of 2008
to 2010 the housing market can be uh
kind of volatile you only need to just
look up you know one of the house price
indices over the last 30 years and
you'll see it's definitely not a
straight line it does go up and down so
just keep looking at the medium term is
this going to suit your finances if
you're looking three five seven years
out and then you can make individual
decisions about what best suits you for
where you want to live and how you want
to live in the years ahead
well thanks to Rachel tegronia and to
garprit this Edition was produced by
Emery Woodhouse with Alex Eden our
editor is Adam G